what do you do when you don't trust
yourself I have pivoted so many times
gotten far and I decid to Pivot it again
because I knew the trend was going
somewhere else I think you need to look
at what you're chasing are you chasing
recognition are you chasing money that's
what's happening there you're chasing
but why do you want to be known as
Innovative or are all of these things
just not your love and you're just
looking for the thing that is sizzly or
financially interesting or something all
together different you got to really
like look yourself in the mirror like
it's all one big game of like you can
lie to everybody but you have to stop
lying to yourself attention is the
number one
asset